I've got it really unique since the
style I like to dress like a comic-book
character if you pay just before she
realizes she has powers I like dressing
like a five-year-old whose dad has her
for the weekend that's my look and so
usually what people will call me like
interesting or quirky they call me sassy
a bunch sassy doesn't have a definition
I know that cuz I looked it up because
I'm lonely huh so look at I've been
sassy means saucy what's that right
saucy means pert what's that that's a
shampoo look up Kurt's definition is
sassy you guys that's an Illuminati
level of deception right there
[Applause]
but like even though there's not a clear
definition we still know what Sasi means
right like they just can't put
see I got called sassy a bunch growing
up I'm from the Rio Grande Valley I was
the only black kid growing up no one was
really racist to me or anything they
were super pumped to have a scary spice
for their little skin and I think they
were too busy being racist to their own
respective races like self racism is a
big thing this is what I've noticed did
you guys know that the derogatory term
for a white girl is white girl tell me
about that
my white sisters in the audience listen
up if someone calls you a white girl to
your face that's not your friend okay
they're making fun of you shots have
been fired also if you're being called
that you should maybe put your shoes on
you're in public we're doing white girl
stuff you're at a bank not Coachella
calm down no one was really racist to me
and I'm using that word correctly cuz
racist is a very misused word I hear
wrong definitions all the time always
two wrong definitions first one I hear
is anything that even mentions the word
black is potentially racist
I'll have here people having
conversations they'll be like I didn't
even like black pepper
who is that racist
[Music]
well it wasn't before
unless you're referring to half of the
group that's saying push it as black
pepper for the second definition I hear
people will use the word racist to
describe when a white person does black
people stuff how is it racist for a
white person to do black people stuff
but it's not racist to think that
there's black people stuff
[Music]
thank you why you guys as white guilt is
that a high I'm gonna go ahead and
continue anytime people talk about black
people stuff or acting black it's always
the same thing I've noticed this it's
always jive talkin pimp walking neck
rockin snaps it's some stuff you would
see on a McDonald's commercial no one
ever says oh man she came up with 200
uses for the peanut she's acting black
sounds like most y'all got that joke but
if you didn't you need to dig into Black
History Month next time it comes around
okay peanut butter was us how not me
personally but people with my skin tone
and curl pattern we fix your jelly
sandwiches so you're welcome oh and it's
funny the kind of things that you'll
notice when you're actually paying
attention like you'll notice not all
inspiring phrases are inspirational like
you've all heard the one dance like no
one's watching
someone probably put it on your Facebook
wall with butterflies trying to inspire
you it's not inspirational that phrase
literally says hey you should be
yourself but in private oh like you
should be yourself regardless of who's
there regardless of who's watching that
is a point they should change that
phrase I think they should change it to
dance like you are not the father
because not a single one of you knows a
more uninhibited dance than the one that
follows the fact that a national
television audience saw that you're not
paying child support